okay so part two of attack on titan
season four had more deaths than all the
previous seasons combined and in this
video we're about to go through each
episode to work out how many people
won't be making it to part three in
order for a death to be included in the
kill count the only criteria is that it
needs to either be shown on screen or
referenced by another character but
sometimes we'll also be using common
sense to add to the number depending on
the context before we begin don't forget
to smash that sub button if you want to
see more attack on titan content like
this and if you're new to the channel
then be sure to check out the killcount
video from last year that covered the
first 16 episodes
okay so episode 17 begins with the
malian army invading shigachina and the
anime did a great job of showing how
brutal this war actually was for example
around halfway through the malians just
start unloading onto the scouts and this
scene held to demonstrate the huge
difference in resources between the two
sides i reckon at least a hundred albums
were taken out in this moment by itself
and it's crazy to imagine how high the
kill count would have been if civilians
hadn't already been evacuated later in
the episode the carnage continues with
the malian soldiers launching grenades
at unsuspecting scouts and as far as i
could tell the cervical were only able
to injure one single marlin in response
overall this opening episode for part 2
was a one-sided massacre but luckily
things start to turn around in episode
18 thanks to the arrival of zeke after
being saved from the brink of death by
emir the beast titan makes this grand
entrance where he wipes out five of
marley's airships in terms of pure
numbers this would be around 50
casualties considering that the vast
majority of soldiers already parachuted
into the district zeke then follows up
by changing his target to the marlins on
the ground and by doing this he helped
to clear a path for eren to reach him
however before the two of them are able
to make contact the cart titan fakes her
own death which causes both zeke and the
igress to let their guard down in the
process nearly the entire group of
jaegerson or mario were ambushed with
flock being the sole survivor and at the
same time magath gets a clean shot that
tears through half of the beast titan
spine meanwhile arm and mikasa and the
other prisoners were freed from their
cells and allowed to fight directly
leading to several malian soldiers
getting blown up by thunderspears at
this stage the war was slowly turning
into more of an even contest and in a
weird way things got better for the
scouts once zeke turned half their army
into pure titans although it is sad that
pixes and the rest of them were turned
into monsters it's undeniable that them
being pure titans made it way easier to
fight back against the invasion across
the ganchiner every last marlin soldier
would either be eaten alive by these
things or dealt with by the scouts with
mcgath being one of the only regular
humans who was able to escape from the
front lines before we skip too far ahead
though we should probably mention that
when zeke did his scream the electricity
from falco's titan fried colt to a crisp
this death was especially tragic for two
reasons number one because cult was
betrayed by a person who was meant to be
his mentor and number two the warrior
candidate sacrificed himself so that he
could be with his younger brother as he
transformed following the transformation
pure titan falco then makes arguably the
most significant kill from part 2 as he
inherits the draw titan by chewing
galliard to pieces this was only the
second time this season that a titan
shifter had been killed by someone but
in porko's case he willingly allowed it
to happen since he didn't have enough
stamina to heal his existing injuries
now after this moment there weren't any
more fatalities for episode 19 besides
some random background shoulders getting
eaten but still it'd be weird to move on
without highlighting eren's near-death
experience in this iconic scene the yaga
bros were just meters away from making
contact but gabby who quite literally
never misses a shot manages to hit his
neck with an anti-titan rifle this sends
aaron's head spinning through the air
and it's undeniable that if he had
landed anywhere else other than zeke's
hand then that would have been the end
of attack on titan fortunately for us
the story continues with both brothers
ending up in the past dimension and in
episode 20 the kill count gets added to
when aaron convinces grisha to squash
the royal family in total this meant the
death of six people including five of
historia's siblings but as we know rod
rice was able to escape so that one day
he could be blown up by the scouts
instead
speaking of the royal family episode 21
takes us 2 thousand years into the past
where we get to witness the origin of
the royal bloodline during this
backstory we see that ymir lived in a
tiny village that couldn't have had a
population of more than 300 and most of
them were wiped out when the eldians
chose to invade some time after this
king fritz used emir's founding titan to
destroy a small army of malian soldiers
and years later after she gave birth to
mario she personally crushes an even
larger group of soldiers with their bare
hands these defeats caused the marlins
to feel a ton of resentment towards the
alien empire and when they arrived to
surrender to fitz one of the soldiers
had pre-planted a spear on the ground
which they then used to throw at the
king unfortunately fritz wasn't the one
to take the head as you may have jumped
in the way to protect him and
surprisingly this attack did kill her
mainly because she didn't have the will
to live the malian assassin who threw
the spear was then sliced to pieces by
nearby aldean guards and in the manga
version of this scene it's shown that
the guards also killed the soldiers who
were kneeling next to him when it comes
to king fritz himself he ended up on his
deathbed presumably due to natural
causes and we know it couldn't have been
that long after the assassination
attempt since his daughters hadn't
really grown much between the two
incidents switching over to aaron
activating the rumbling in the present
day this instantly caused the deaths of
thousands of eldians across parodies
island the main reason for these deaths
was that aaron crumbled all three walls
without giving people time to prepare
which meant that anyone who lived next
to them had a high chance of being
crushed when we take a quick look at
this map shigachina was the only town
near the walls that had already been
evacuated whereas the remaining
districts like trost and stowers had
extensive casualties and we saw this in
episode 22. a safe estimate would be
that around 400 people per district were
flattened which is easily more than 4
000 alden deaths caused by aaron overall
now back in trigancina zeke's pure
titans had finished eating all the
malian soldiers and began turning their
attention to the surviving scouts during
the chaos a handful of scouts were
explicitly shown to either be smushed or
eaten alive and you'd have to imagine
there were an extra 20 to 30 soldiers we
didn't see who probably got the same
treatment eventually though jean was
able to lead the scouts to kill every
pure titan in the district with the two
most significant deaths being pixies and
nile in nars case gabby killed him using
the same rifle she used to decapitate
eren and in pixis's case a very sorry
armin had to blow him up using a
thunderspear following this the next
death came from one of the anti-marlin
volunteers who was murdered by flock to
show the other volunteers what could
happen flock's main goal at this point
was to eliminate people on the island
who didn't support the alien empire and
of course the volunteers weren't exactly
keen on helping given that aaron was
about to destroy their homelands the
volunteer who flock executed was the
most vocal out of the group and his
death did have some kind of impact as it
made jon question whether he was on the
right side
in episode 24 hanji and levi were being
hunted down by the yagaris and while
hiding in the forest the commander
tearfully shoots two soldiers that were
chasing after them later on it's heavily
implied that these two weren't the only
ones they had to kill and when we
flashed back to when hanji first escaped
we do see there was a third person they
must have killed off screen around
halfway through the episode things then
switch over to a random hospital where
mikasa pays a visit to louise while it's
true that louise doesn't die in this
exact moment she reveals that she has
shrapnel inside her system which is
basically a death sentence for anyone
who doesn't have one of these things
what makes her death especially tragic
is that it could have been prevented
because the only reason she got hurt was
that she spent too much time staring at
mikasa in the middle of a war zone it
was this distraction that led to her
getting caught up in the explosion but
if she'd been paying attention then
she'd very likely still be alive
anyway moving on episode 25 was the
first and only episode from part 2 not
to have a single person die primarily
because most of the runtime was the
alliance having various debates and
beating each other up by the end though
they did eventually make it to the
harbour which is when the kill count
dramatically began to increase for a
start hanji mentions how the yeagers
have killed four people already
referring to the azmobito engineers who
were likely shot by flock on top of that
based on the speed of the titans the
commander worked out that several malian
cities on the coast had already been
trampled although we don't have an exact
figure it's safe to assume that a few
coastal cities is equivalent to at least
a couple million people and remember
this doesn't even factor in liberia it
wasn't until much later on that hanji
realized liberia would also be crushed
as well which by my estimation adds
another 500 000 civilians to the kill
count it's important to remember that
liberio is more than just the people
inside the internment zone as it also
has large sections where malians live
and work not to mention tens of
thousands of soldiers who do special
training up in the mountains
now when it comes to the alliance
despite armin trying to take the
peaceful path he couldn't prevent things
turning into an all-out war between the
scouts and the agres in the beginning of
this war hanji and magath killed three
jaegers inside one of the main buildings
while annie and reina pummeled nearly 10
soldiers with their bare hands meanwhile
next to the flying boat connie made the
gut-wrenching choice to execute daz and
samuel who are two friends that he's
known ever since their time in the
cadets ultimately connie had to make
this decision in order for the alliance
to have a chance of stopping eren and in
the background the warriors continued to
get a nice amount of kills with mikasa
joining the action as well when the
fighting first began she did actually
hurt to jaegerus already although it
wasn't clear if she killed them but
assuming that she knocked them
unconscious the two soldiers would have
been blown to pieces when other jaegers
fired into the room anyhow magath and
hanji added to their kill streets while
the azmobito tried to escape however a
train full of jaeger's reinforcements
was heading towards the harbour in total
there were 9 visible carriages with
roughly 15 soldiers each which we can
round up to 150 overall if those
reinforcements had made it to where they
needed to be then the alliance for sure
would have been overwhelmed by the
numbers hence why instructor chad has
stepped in to blow it up by doing what
he did he gave the alliance their final
chance of surviving and in the next
scene when annie and reina were about to
be killed connie saves them by
single-handedly wiping out five jaegris
mikasa follows that up by slicing four
of them herself and in total i guess
that around 80 plus jagras were taken
out by this small group of fighters on
one hand you could argue that it's
realistic given that these are the
island's best soldiers besides captain
levi but personally i did think it was
kind of weird that they were able to get
through this without anyone being shot
or taking serious damage to their human
bodies regardless once the battle was
over general mcgath stayed behind to
make sure the yaegris wouldn't be able
to chase after the alliance and in the
process he and charles had a bit of a
team up on his introduction the
instructor personally killed a couple of
soldiers that were chasing after mcgath
and then the two men boarded one of the
nearby cruisers their plan was to
destroy this thing so that the jaegers
couldn't use it but to do this mission
it involved them getting blown up as
well technically speaking shardis had
the option to leave the ship and survive
if he wanted to but he already made it
clear that he didn't see a future on the
island while people like flock were in
charge as a consequence both of them
died when magath ignites the gunpowder
and it evaporates everybody on board
including the enemy soldiers
finally moving on to the grand finale of
part 2 all the casualties in this one
came in the last few minutes of the
episode on the malian coast the global
military alliance had assembled the
strongest cannons humanity had to offer
and overall there were over 90
battleships confirmed by this screenshot
here if the average crew size is 120 men
per ship then that's easily 10 000 plus
soldiers not to mention the thousands
more who are on dry land the cannons
then begin firing towards the rumbling
and to be fair they do some damage to
the colossal titans in the front but it
didn't take a second for the hordes of
titans behind them to overtake these
monsters then swim underneath the ships
causing most of them to be flung into
the air by the hot steam but some
unlucky soldiers on board did also get
burned up before that happened gradually
all 10 000 men would be wiped out when
their ships exploded on impact and on
the shore scores of malian troops begin
to abandon their stations as error
marches forward we then get a bird's eye
view of the rumbling destroying
everything although the kill count
wouldn't be as high as you'd expect
since most of the city had already been
evacuated if there were any civilians
then we would have seen them running in
the streets alongside the malian
soldiers but the fact we don't see
anyone implies that the only people left
were involved with the military for that
reason the count only increases by about
15 000 but obviously if aaron keeps
marching then he'll eventually catch up
to all the civilians who tried to run
away
with that said that is the complete kill
count for part 2 of the final season and
like i mentioned in the intro this is
easily more than all the previous
seasons combined if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a like and hit
that sub button so you don't miss new
uploads like this and until the next one
peace out